how's Gomes - beautiful welcome back to
another episode of corpse party
we are heading out after God Oh
on closer inspection there's no visible
bolt keeping the door closed nor any
other evidence that it's been locked at
all
god damn it we're tribe so cook up the
night on you because your [ __ ] tonight
fine well I don't know what to do then
oh Jesus
okay some [ __ ] is after us I think so
I do think so okay so you brothers have
been telling me [ __ ] goes down in this
episode so I'm really curious what's
gonna happen I don't like it at all
[Music]
wonderful sorry now me you're [ __ ]
can I move I know what's going up ah
[ __ ] what's going on with her maybe we
should go back to sleep no I don't think
we can do anything I think we just wait
it out right right basis let's see if we
can go out finally nope
oh Jesus the door is lad it said what
the [ __ ] with countless strands of black
hair rooting in its place god damn it
black hair that's [ __ ] creepy man oh
god oh god oh god okay it's someone
there I got goose nips all over
it sounds like a ballpoint pen
scribbling away on the sheet of paper
what is that oh jesus don't get me
oh god it's a red spirit I can't go
there what the [ __ ] oh god no what Oh
Oh God what is that I need to get away
oh god where does that come from got out
back try using the match to burn the
hair yes
run [ __ ] run the play wasn't strong
enough to do this a line I got black and
Miss begins to wrap itself for I know
miss buddy there's no question that this
is a male only force if this continuous
def isn't have inevitably come on take
it the previously operated SMS has been
a natural almost ether no bull then do
something with
[Music]
black mist begins flowing into now his
body through her nose her mouth her ears
her eyes in no time at all she's
completely engulfed gasped choked with
vision darkening and consciousness
fading the last thing Noemi ever sees Oh
God no jesus [ __ ] christ
it's the wiggly greening verge of a
woman she's never seen before
what wrong end yeah
damn it don't try to hi-fi me no you
know what I'm gonna redo that [ __ ] okay
okay we're doing it we go down yes yes
the plane wasn't strong enough god
dammit god dammit oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god come on
I got it I got it I'm [ __ ] I get it
here vast quantities of medicine Jess
take it take the alcohol Jess okay we
got alcohol and [ __ ] all right
Oh Oh God maybe you can okay go go go oh
[ __ ]
stop this nonsense yes use alcohol and
then yes
after he sees flashing alcohol along the
edge of the Rome isolate imagine an
attempt to burn
yes we got it yes a sizable portion
below go yes
[ __ ] you wrong in Oh God where do we go
Oh God not more goddamn it I'm going to
kill you Oh God
okay this is so [ __ ] up oh god damn it
patter patter yes save us no we're not
okay
we're so [ __ ]
don't apologize now kiss okay what she
wants to rub her ass probably
you gotta probably know what
yeah buddy cook when you are each later
still you name it die well we heard them
it doesn't make sense
but we heard them why are they not
worried about the spirit that said that
we're gonna kill them no it's not okay
Karuna you dammit I know that the dictum
by raishin what the [ __ ] is that I'm not
sure yet
uh yeah well let's go and they all HeLa
probably the best idea you could do
Konya how old are these girls supposed
to be like their boobs are freakin
gigantic the saying like I'm a lot
better cosa be no gender dojo yep
yeah bye mother
yeah you being negative in shape you
just want to give up yeah you are Saeko
is the nice one she's keeping it out no
you're not bitter she yeah she needs a
good education I wasn't you gonna okay
okay that's the plane
Jesus why you being such a [ __ ] yeah
that's right
Saeko you listen to her know me Naniwa
salt emotional don't you [ __ ] swear to
her you [ __ ] doctor ooh he's trying to
keep the spirit okay be nice Tony de la
cultura to zero
now me I don't like you anymore Nando
canarios anak DISA that's a crock and
you know it so you see many other guruva
totally dismantle yep sequel gang kids
cute or not the tateshina kiss a para
skidded on Soraka conocida como go come
on skit isn't he lucky dusty smell come
up the cutest Ione hero I could about
that it's Kara that's no kokoro no Kai
Ocala okay it'll need a touchy decision
you are I think she knows it but why
don't see she doesn't do anything about
it
she buys their studies there can she
just shut the [ __ ] up for one second me
look you see what I let you go y'all
that's right sick oh no no no okay you
know what you know I still gotta get I
gotta study gonna you know Gaza sooner -
I suppose they don't know stick thingy
no sorry I stopped there so kangaroo
monogenic Corolla do you don't like it
sue
no I'm a dad I can't I gotta take it are
you guys not know we just saw her that
hat what happens when they did that
don't leave I'm not sure nice you know
it's not you [ __ ] yeah then do it well
it's an obvious choice
why is is even a choice and you [ __ ]
do it
apologize yes
no I mean I so spying or not no no no no
don't don't split up huh you heard him
you [ __ ] Wow
wow wow wow how is this a better ending
mother : data has no Wan Azizah Guinea
sonzai suru koto Matt Akita artist
achieved a diva yeah Canton II can't go
across - Samantha yeah Society legit
Purina walking up Pocoyo Monaco Tony not
ANOVA Jesus guys
senator savino quotient are you cereal
well at least it's not over and now
we're getting now count that for sake of
[Laughter]
the soundtrack
[Music]
got it quite young
damn what who follow the voice this is a
question well I don't know okay you know
what
fine I'll follow it I don't like this
please aa first time of what buttering
your pooper no I know
ah the first time you okay I got it is
she coming after us
what is going on she's not a dog sucking
a cure for you guys oh no no me you
gotta be strong they would she not that
the stuff maybe that's what happened to
Seco see cool so no no go huh city mad
no no my yo-yo be negara cadaver dog I
thought she goes you know some kinda
third floor hallway god I don't like
this
Oh goddamnit
for now me oh god no she can't die
I'm gonna be pissed if she dies no
that's not steak oh no it's not we
already investigated all this I know
where we are
this is why the
Oh God Oh God I got goose nips they're
coming
hello the pee bucket save me oh yes the
maggots [ __ ] all right we're going in oh
yeah this oh it's in there oh god then
go away oh god no what the [ __ ] oh she's
alive do something the news around Oh
strangling her further oh god what do I
do
uh CEQA
maybe if I go upstairs I don't know okay
dumb that was dumb we can't go upstairs
what do i do what do I do
I don't bucket yes yes yes bucket will
save us oh god I got this give me [ __ ]
up sorry
a nice God come on hurry up save sake no
no
[Music]
up until just a few hours before I was
laughing and playing a school when my
best friend
now he or she was right in front of my
eyes
lifeless hanging from a noose how could
I possibly accept that as a reality
[Music]
oh it's a party all right
jesus [ __ ] hell man
that's [ __ ] ah see so it's like my god
they weren't kidding huh
really it's [ __ ] crazy this game
Jesus
all right I'm gonna have to end it there
I don't know I can keep playing but go
ahead and leave a like if you enjoy
watching brush its sky camera today and
I will see breaths in chapter 2 thank
you for showing your spoiling series I
really appreciate it sale summers love
you
[Music]